in the aftermath of the disastrous exxon
valdez oil spill of 1989 the scp
foundation received a tip about some
anomalous plant life surrounding the
affected area plants there were
beginning to mutate and change for
seemingly no reason with concerns about
pollution on everyone's mind it seemed
possible that the plant life had been
directly affected by the oil spill
itself after all humanity's destructive
impact on the earth had already become
noticeable even decades ago however when
the foundation showed up to investigate
they found something much stranger all
of the mutated plants had a common
substance on them in their pollen seeds
roots or the surrounding soil and we're
not talking about the millions of
gallons of spilled crude oil no one had
ever seen this substance before and all
tests on it proved inconclusive they
collected samples of it and began
extensive studies on what would become
known as scp-1100
though scp-1100 was initially classified
as safe in the foundation records it
would quickly reveal itself to be
anything but the first entry in
scp-1100's official file described it as
a complex organic substance that causes
anomalous transformations in natural
plant life it can be transmitted between
plants by way of pollen and seeds within
72 hours an infected plant becomes
dangerous or hostile to human life
during testing foundation researchers
exposed a variety of edible plants to
scp-1100
artificially pollinating the plants with
samples of the compound tomatoes apples
strawberries carrots and cabbage were
among the plants tested as the fruits
and vegetables ripened many visual
differences became apparent right away
the skin of the tomatoes thickened and
darkened into an off-putting leathery
brown until it was incredibly difficult
to bite through or even slice into with
a knife when the tomatoes were finally
cut into pieces the flesh was coarse and
dry the cabbage took on the appearance
of rotten food growing a fine layer of
mold as the leaves became slick and oily
the strawberries sprouted incredibly
sharp thorns where ordinary strawberries
simply had seeds becoming unsafe to eat
the carrots and apples were visibly
unchanged but had some unfortunate side
effects when fed to d-class personnel at
the site the carrots induced nearly
instantaneous vomiting and dizziness
triggering a seizure in one particularly
unfortunate subject the apples on the
other hand had developed hard sharp
structures near the core much like the
classic urban legend of the razer blade
hidden in the halloween apple personnel
who sampled the fruit suffered
lacerations to their gums tongue and
roof of the mouth whether through
disgusting appearance tougher skin and
thorns or harmful side effects all of
the plants were rendered completely
inedible initial containment procedures
were not terribly strict
scp-1100 was kept within the secure
biohazardous material storage unit at
biocontainment site 33 this seemed to
adequately contain the substance until
one day during a bit of routine
scientific testing a large amount of
scp-1100 was gathered for
experimentation when out of nowhere it
vaporized disappearing into the air not
only did it contaminate the plant life
specifically set aside for the
experiment but it traveled through the
vents and infected all the plant life
being grown at the site specifics of the
incident have been redacted from the
record but 70 percent of the on-site
personnel were killed in this
containment breach in the aftermath the
remainder of scp-1100 was moved to
biocontainment site-26 the object's
class formerly listed as safe was
upgraded to euclid after it was
transferred to site-26 experimentation
with scp-1100 resumed after being
exposed to the substance this new round
of plants transformed in a variety of
ways within 48 hours with increasingly
disturbing results a mango tree
underwent a chemical transformation the
fruit previously ripe and fragrant
became filled with highly corrosive acid
when touched the transformed mangoes
would burst spraying this caustic liquid
all over the person who touched them
long vines of common ivy developed
muscle-like internal structures one poor
d-class made the mistake of putting his
hand a bit too close to an infected ivy
plant only to have it wrap around his
hand and crush the bone into powder
before he could get away a rose bush's
thorns elongated hardening and
sharpening to the point comparable to a
knife another rose bush excreted a toxic
substance from its thorns that when
tested was found to be similar to the
type of neurotoxin found in the deadly
cone snail as these experiments
continued at site site-26 several of the
researchers assigned to scp-1100 noticed
that it would become increasingly
dangerous to contain and that its
effects were becoming stronger more
pronounced and taking effect much more
quickly at this point no source could be
found for the substance though a theory
was posited by dr smith that it was the
creation of a radical environmentalist
group with access to resources and
technology on the same level as the
foundation a task force was put together
to monitor environmentalist groups
around the globe for possible hints
about the creator of scp-1100
during the course of the experiments at
site-26 as cp 1100 vaporized
spontaneously again it spread throughout
the office in record time wiping out 96
of the on-site personnel at that point
in a desperate attempt to stop the
infection from spreading to the other
sites or even into the civilian world a
research assistant made the choice to
detonate the on-site nuclear warhead the
infection was stopped but all remaining
surviving personnel were killed in the
blast and the surrounding area afflicted
with irreparable damage
scp-1100 was moved to a triple redundant
hermetically sealed container stored in
a containment chamber at an unlisted
foundation site the container is checked
daily to ensure that it is still
completely intact and able to hold the
substance if anything should happen to
the container as cp 1100 is to be
immediately transferred to a new one
after the devastating loss of site-26
and additional experimentation
scp-1100 class was changed from euclid
to ketter this allowed the foundation to
allocate additional resources to its
containment seeing as safe and euclid
containment procedures had both resulted
in catastrophic loss of human life and
in both instances they had been
profoundly lucky that it hadn't been
worse after determining that exposure to
scp-1100 would make edible plants unfit
for consumption and heighten the danger
of otherwise normally innocuous plants
the foundation became curious about the
effects the substance might have on
animal test subjects a variety of
species were selected for the animal
trials including deer mice cows chickens
cats and dogs the deer and the mice both
ordinarily considered to be docile prey
animals in the wild were the first to be
exposed to scp-1100
within 24 hours they had become much
stronger and more aggressive one of the
deer was able to break down the door of
an observation room by ramming against
it with its head once it had broken out
of the room it proceeded to charge and
attack any person that it saw the mice
became prone to swarming researchers and
biting them wherever they could with jaw
strength capable of biting through
hazmat suits and even biting one
person's finger clean off any attempts
to subdue the animals were futile the
creatures somehow fighting off even the
strongest sedative the only way to
prevent the infected deer and mice from
continuing to attack was to terminate
them next the cows and chickens were
exposed to scp-1100
they did not display any behavioral
changes once exposed nor did they show
any increased strength the cows and
chickens continued to behave normally
going about their days as if nothing had
changed they did not respond to the
presence of humans with the exception of
feeding times during which they would
approach only to eat their food a
selection of the livestock were
slaughtered in order to perform an
autopsy and look for anomalies in their
bodies everything looked unchanged until
some of the meat was prepared for
consumption and given to a selection of
d-class personnel the beef taken from
the infected cows was impossible to
digest causing a dramatic amount of
gastric upset cramping and vomiting
testing showed that inexplicably it had
no identifiable nutritional value the
chicken on the other hand became highly
toxic showing lethal levels of cyanide
and arsenic naturally present in its
flesh when tested like with the fruits
and vegetables exposure to scp-1100 made
the cows and chickens impossible for
human beings to eat the cats and dogs
were the last to be experimented on no
matter how docile and friendly the
animals were at first within 24 hours
they had become vicious at the sight of
any human they would attempt to attack
like the deer and mice they could not be
subdued by any level of sedative
displaying shocking levels of strength
and resilience for their size one
d-class lost his arm and another had his
eyes clawed out before the subjects
could be terminated whatever scp-1100
was it made everything it touched
dangerous to humans even man's best
friend could be convinced to turn on him
in only a single day as might have been
expected given the significant loss of
life and the destruction of two
different foundation sites
experimentation with scp-1100 has been
suspended until further notice the
substance went from affecting plants and
animals within 72 hours to accomplishing
it in 48 and then 24 it is becoming more
efficient and more dangerous if allowed
to continue adapting it could someday
transform infected organisms in only a
minute if the substance ever escapes
containment again defoliants and
desiccants are to be deployed within a
one kilometer radius of the infected
area and the area must be quarantined
for 12 months if the situation becomes
dire enough nuclear or chemical weapons
may be deployed in order to distract the
public and provide an acceptable
explanation for the quarantine how had
things gone so horribly wrong so fast
bits of surveillance video were
recovered from the ruins of site-26
providing a glimpse into what exactly
happened before the entire site was
destroyed the footage pieced together is
not entirely conclusive but here's what
we know for sure a foundation researcher
referred to as dr v disarmed and shot
the armed guard at the entrance to
scp-1100s containment facility while he
did this another foundation researcher
known as dr m entered the containment
and took the sample of scp-1100 out the
footage cuts off for a while here but it
becomes clear when the video resumes
that dr v and dr m dumped part of the
sample into the site's water supply and
vaporized the rest of it into the air
this is believed to be the cause of the
mass contamination that occurred at the
site which was previously thought to
have been accidental dr v and dr m were
later linked to an environmentalist
organization on the foundation's watch
list during the investigation of dr v
and dr m a diary was discovered from dr
v's home in it he wrote about his
personal theories regarding scp-1100 and
where it might have come from while his
colleagues proposed scp-1100 was some
sort of deliberately engineered
bioweapon dr v believed it to have a far
more organic point of origin he stated
plainly it's a planetary immune response
it's gaia mother earth fighting back
against us the more we try to fight it
the worse it gets she wants us all dead
wants us gone because of what we've done
to her and there's nothing we can do to
stop it he concluded the entry with the
assertion that the only thing humanity
can do now is accept the punishment the
earth wishes to give us this was his
final entry before he and dr m triggered
the destruction of site-26 were the
doctors right should we just accept that
the earth is done with humanity and
ready to drive us to extinction before
we can do any further damage the jury is
still out on that perhaps we can turn
back the clock mitigate the harm done to
the natural world and attempt to earn
back its favor before it's too late but
if scp-1100 ever makes its way out of
containment and reaches the plants and
animals of our world turning them all
against us one by one we won't have much
of a choice now go check out scp-xk
class end of the world scenarios
explained and scp-2000 deus ex machina
for more scps that could cause or
prevent the end of the world as we know
it